2029, les techniques de maquillage et de beauté sur Youtube ont tellement évolué qu'il est devenu dangereux de les apprendre à n'importe qui.
L'Etat a donc décidé d'interdire toutes ces vidéos mais plutôt que de perdre ces compétences à jamais il a eu la bonne idée de les mettre au service des citoyens par le biais d'une unité spéciale.
Voici leur histoire ...
Shera, la situation est plus que critique, si le docteur Erad craque et dit au mercenaire tout ce qu'il sait nous sommes perdus.
J'ai besoin de votre aide.
Je vous ai déjà parlé de notre spécialiste de l'apparence ?
Non ?
Elle est très photogénique. Il est impossible de prendre une mauvaise photo d'elle, même sur les caméras de surveillance elle est toujours "on fleek".
Incroyable.
Ce n'est pas tout, nous avons aussi notre spécialiste du "all in". Elle peut tout faire rentrer dans une valise ou même un sac.
Sinon nous avons notre spécialiste en modification capillaire. Elle fait ce qu'elle veut de sa chevelure, se faire une coupe en forme de clé pour ouvrir une porte par exemple, puis nous avons ...
Shera le temps presse !
Toutes ces filles sont extraordinaires certes, mais nous devons surtout prendre une décision.
Je voulais juste vous entendre dire qu'elles sont extraordinaires.
Quoi ?
Si je vous disais que la meilleure est déjà sur le coup ?
Mais je croyais qu'elle n'acceptait plus aucune mission ?
Estimez-vous chanceux.
Là, on commence vraiment à perdre patience !
Oh que ouais, putain !
File-nous les codes !
Si je vous donne les codes, votre patron va tout faire sauter ! C'est un malade.
Et si je te tire une balle dans le genou ? Peut-être que ça va te faire parler.
Ouais ! Fais-ça, fais-ça, fais-ça.
Il va tout faire sauter je vous dis, même vous !
J'en ai rien à foutre.
Un, deux ...
Vous êtes ... ? Une youtubeuse ?
Oui.
Je suis sauvé !
Pas tout à fait.
Qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
Je le maquille afin qu'on ait l'impression qu'il fait une sieste, ça évitera les soupçons.
Bien joué !
Et maintenant ?
Je maquille cette chaise en lit pour justifier le fait qu'il se soit endormi.
Incroyable.
Ne perdons pas de temps.
J'ai tout vu.
On est fichu.
Tout va bien se passer.
Tant que je n'ai pas les codes, personne ne partira d'ici.
La vie à l'air de réussir aux youtubeuses.
Noam et ses toys ...
Ouais, on m'exploitait Nathalie.
De mes six à mes dix ans j'ai travaillé autant qu'un adulte.
Tous les soirs, je testais des jouets ! Tous les soirs ! "Noam a des nouveaux handspinners", "vous ne devinerez jamais où Noam s'est baigné" ! Et qu'est-ce que j'en tire moi de tout ça ? Mes parents se sont séparés ...
J'ai jamais vu l'argent de ces putains de vidéos et je déteste ce putain de rayon jouet ! Alors maintenant c'est à moi de jouer avec les gens hein, c'est mon tour !
Et je vais tout faire péter ! Ahh je vais tout faire péter !
Elle est où putain ?
Je suis là.
Ou peut-être là
Et bah alors, Noam ? Je croyais que tu voulais jouer ?
Fais chier !
Fin du game, Noam.
Vous nous avez tous sauvés.
Je n'ai fait que mon devoir.
Vous savez que j'avais une chaîne youtube à l'époque ?
Ah oui ?
Ouais ouais, je faisais John Moxim de microscope.
AH
Salut les pélos ! Vous voulez que j'ouvre le nouveau Zeizei dix 300 ?
Non.
Non non mais c'est pas une vraie question, c'est la phrase que je disais au début des vidéos.
Ouais mais la réponse est quand même non.
D'accord.